[Music]
in recent years Disney has unveiled
culturally diverse princesses to its
lineup but for those who crave even more
diversity these altered photos created
by a talented artist named titi of the
tumblr vlog
let there be doodles will amaze you if
you're new to our channel don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up because today we'll be
sharing 10 alternate stories of Disney
Princesses in other countries just wait
until you see the new version of
Princess Jasmine it's guaranteed to
shock you Cinderella we definitely did a
double-take when we saw this alternate
version of Cinderella the characters
European features are long gone she's
now turned into a Geisha a traditional
Japanese female entertainer her rags
have been converted into a beautiful
kimono and an Obi tied around her waist
she also wears the traditional white
makeup that covers her entire face and
neck Aurora we're all used to seeing
Princess Aurora look like this and
that's why we're absolutely floored when
we saw her brand new look the original
Aurora has fair skin blond hair and
violet eyes now take a look at the
Jamaican version of the Sleeping Beauty
character her skin is golden brown and
she wears her hair in traditional
dreadlocks would you watch a Jamaican
version of this film let us know down
below Elsa Elsa may be from arendelle
but in the artist TT's rendition she's
transformed into a Mexican princess
their frozen character wears antique
gold jewelry encrusted with rubies and a
traditional floral headdress with
cascading flowers adorning her dark hair
how beautiful do you think she looks let
us know if you prefer the original Elsa
or her new look in the comment section
Pocahontas Pocahontas has been
captivating Disney fans ever since the
1995 release of the film with her long
dark hair and dark features we didn't
think this Native American princess
could get any more beautiful but she
just did check out this photo of the
artist's rendition of a Pacific Islander
version of the princess her
eyes are much whiter her nose is broader
and she has some fabulous beachy waves
in her hair to complete her look a red
hibiscus flower sits behind her ear
snow-white the original Snow White is a
German character with light skin and
dark hair and eyes but check out this
brand-new version of the Disney Princess
Snow White is now a Latina woman with
olive skin
she wears a festive red dress with
ruffles on the shoulders and her hair is
styled in an updo with a flower pinned
to the side to pay homage to Latin
folklore Megara Megara the wife of
Hercules is a stunning Greek beauty but
the character went through a total
transformation to become an ancient
Egyptian in this picture you can see
just how much mcGarry's features and
clothing have been changed to fit in
with traditional Egyptian attire the
ancient Egyptians would wear lavish
jewellery to signify their wealth and
the updated version of Megara is
dripping in jewels she wears a gold
headdress gold earrings in a traditional
gold armband and we can't get enough of
her new makeup how gorgeous does she
look with her darkly rimmed eyes and
teal eye shadow jasmine Aladdin's
Princess Jasmine continues to wow us
with her good looks her flawless hair
and her dazzling outfits but check out
her now the character from the Arabian
city of Agrabah is now a Kenyan princess
jasmine has been transformed into a
Masai woman complete with traditional
face paint beaded jewelry and a colorful
headband even Jasmine's tiger Raja is
transformed into a lion which is a
symbol of Kenya's nationhood Tiana their
world rejoiced when Disney revealed its
first african-american princess tiana
and now the new orleans character has
been revamped to fit into a brand new
culture as an East Asian princess her
eyes were widened and lengthened and
when it comes to her hair it's styled in
a traditional bun do you think it's
about time Disney created an East Asian
princess let us know what you think down
in the comments section Belle Belle is
gorgeous in her own right but we love
this alternate version of The Beauty and
the Beast star and this photo Belle is
transformed into a beautiful Muslim
woman her
skin and her hair have been darkened to
give her a warm glow and she's wearing a
hijab which is a traditional Muslim head
covering wouldn't it be awesome to see a
Muslim version of Beauty and the Beast
Arielle everyone's favorite mermaid just
got a brand new look Ariel's red hair
and blue eyes are long gone and she has
now been recreated as an Indian princess
she wears a gold and purple mang tika in
her hair and a gold nose ring a red
bindi on her forehead and she has a
henna tattoo on her hand do you think
area looks better in her original form
or as an Indian princess which of these
artists recreations of the Disney
Princesses from different cultures did
you love the most
let us know in the comments section and
the most original reply will be pinned
to our channel if you'd like to see more
videos like this don't forget to
subscribe to our channel and give this
video a big thumbs up
[Music]